somebody else is threatening my friend
my friend dustin
okay and his zombie squad so first off
zombie squad represent in the chat
please zombie squad everyone here wanted
to uh
to represent okay okay shout out to the
zombie squad
now
we have somebody else so i'm not
somebody else somebody that we know
that's been bothering my buddy dustin
hello my fellow zombie squads
welcome to the destin tv hi dustin
uh this video
is about nomad sam
the homeless hobo
he's already coming in hot
he's already coming in hot you know what
we need little music he's cause he's
cutting a promo we need a little music
are you ready
[Music]
i think you could tell us what to do you
can't tell dustin what to do
you think you could tell us what to wish
bro not the zombie squad
[Music]
[Music]
nomad sam said to
brandon brown's wife
to his wife
ashley brown they said
use some money you piece of [ __ ]
to help you out sam
but you had the [ __ ] gauze
to threaten you to kill
ashley brown come to her house
and shoot her in a [ __ ] head
let me tell you something [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
if you ever touch ashley brown
i will hurt you [ __ ] homeless
piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
you don't even have a [ __ ] home
you know you have a hip problem i'll
finish breaking the son of a [ __ ] for
you
you piece of [ __ ]
you're gonna you're gonna come here and
you're gonna
shoot my friend's wife brandon's brown
wife dude
they just they sent you money a couple
of days ago
20 something dollars they donated to sam
and he said he was going to shoot the
wife in the fight are you
i [ __ ] hate sam
who does this [ __ ] think he is
bothering my friend
dustin tv
oh i think i must have
i think i activated something i think i
activated something and dusted
his confidence he's confident and you
know what dustin
confident dustin is my favorite dustin
my favorite one
jesus [ __ ] christ i feel like
with you jumping in to you know like
give him some backing that day he
realized that he has that in him
he's always had it he's always had it
dustin you've always had it in you so
did nomad sam
could somebody research this because who
knows did nomad
sam really threatened to kill
ashley one of his friends one of his og
zombie squad people
did she just really did he really
threaten that
because if that's the case dustin
doesn't seem like a liar
man no no i'll tell you this he's not
you could tell
people like him people like thomas
they're they're they're honest i will
say to a fault
yeah you know i really mean that they're
honest to a fault
your interview with him showed that yeah
he's just open
open book yeah he's very direct
oh and you had the [ __ ] balls
to turn your back on them it says
you are going to shoot his wife in the
[ __ ] head
but i'm going to tell you something that
ain't going to happen because when you
ask that foot in georgia
first thing i'm going to do i'm gonna
officially breaking your [ __ ] hip
piece of [ __ ] oh you can bring all the
[ __ ] trolls in my channel all you
want to
but i'm gonna tell you one thing you
ain't gonna do you ain't gonna
[ __ ] try to kill my friends
you baby glad brandon ain't gonna do
do something to you he allowed me to do
it
but i'ma tell you something sam you
homeless piece of [ __ ]
begging for money
you are the storm of the [ __ ] earth
that's the reason why nobody don't like
you
because all you do is talk about people
and here you are threatening to kill
somebody i just made this video black
and white
i could go up here i made this video
black and white
and give them your videos and tell them
who the [ __ ] you are
and tell them you're threatening to kill
ashley brown coming to shoot her in the
head
you stupid scumbag [ __ ]
definitely more independent i'm going to
tell you something
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] you do not have a home
you go around go all over the country
because
people feel sorry for you you live
in a van
i feel so sorry for them dogs are yours
because they have to deal with your
stupid ass
[Music]
that's the reason why we got a thing for
you sam
homeless sam homeless no
matt sam you're a hobo sam
you're not about a piece of [ __ ] i love
him hey guess what
a lot of people don't like you anymore
yeah they feel sorry for you because
you got a bad hip but let me tell you
something you son of a [ __ ]
you will never step foot
in donald trump because you know why
because i will be
there will you come to donaldsonville
i will have your van
turn i will take your dogs
and give them a better home yeah
my home i will take good care of your
dog
then your ass will be in jail
listen to this do you see this the
things you hear him do you hear them
he's not playing he's not [ __ ]
playing with you
you know for threatening to kill
somebody you son of a [ __ ]
and then guess what they're gonna throw
the book at you
because you're threatening to kill
somebody you [ __ ]
[Music]
i don't care what you do to me but
you don't ever say you're gonna kill my
friend you
stupid son of a [ __ ]
you're nothing but a scumbag of the
earth man
damn you are remind me
of you came out of
lucifer's ass
when lucifer took a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
here comes sam was born
[Laughter]
you're not about a piece of [ __ ] anyway
sam
but if i catch you threaten ashley
brown again she's a friend of mine
and she is a fellow
zombie squad
when you miss one of us you son of a
[ __ ] you mess with
every last one of the zombie squad did
he do it
is he spider-man posting i think he's
spider-man posting
he's a the madman the madman
he's a [ __ ] madman
hold on i think i actually have that
drop
hold on i might have that one
i do have that one i got it
he is spider-man posting check it out
all of us mess with one of us you mess
with
all of us wow
wow uh frozen wants you to know it's
spider skirt
you're right spider skirt i apologize
you son of a [ __ ]
and you only got a cup you got a uh
a couple hundred subscribers
not like dustin who has a 1110
because you're a loser that's right
because everybody see right through you
sam
you're not about a piece of [ __ ] i don't
even know why
i'm you know this phone's ringing
oh wait you only got 160 subscribers
loser oh
is that you with your cigarette in the
mouth you son of a [ __ ]
no matt sam a loser you need to change
your
change your uh channel to instead of
no mad sam to
loser no math sam that's what
he's coming with the fire listen i know
he's mad but some things you can't take
back
that was mean you're going you're being
mean to look okay sam deserves it i get
it
but wow you're [ __ ] ripping him apart
today dustin
but you are you son of a [ __ ]
because guess what no matter him
i don't even know why i am
saving my breath for you you son of a
[ __ ] you're defending your friends
because
i was gonna i feel sorry for you sam
when you got out of your van
and and you had trouble walking because
your hip and then you put them
uh snow on your head
i feel sorry for you i really did
until you threatened my friend
ashley brown that was your first mistake
you piece of [ __ ] this is what you are
sam
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
or you can bring all the [ __ ] trolls
you want but guess guess what
my zombie squad got your [ __ ] trolls
you punk ass
[ __ ] because
anybody is on youtube you do not
threaten somebody
else threatening to come to him
and kill him i mean it's probably it's
not about yes
it is look at that that right there
shows you that he's not [ __ ] playing
around oh is he stone cold in him that
is
that right take a good look take a good
look at this man
and tell me if this is the man you
want to [ __ ] with because i wouldn't
want to [ __ ] with him because he's about
to open a can of skirt ass on you
[Music]
no man sam jehovah what
he lives in a van what
[Music]
he he eats cans of beans
[Music]
[ __ ] love this man we're almost done
with this video though [ __ ] a loser
you [ __ ] [ __ ] if anybody
is subscribed to nomad sam
please don't subscribe because he's a
[ __ ] loser
he don't he don't make good content
all he does is go in people's live
stream
and talk about other people and he makes
stupid ass videos
i don't make stupid ass videos no he
doesn't i do
i will say that jamie i'm honestly i do
reaction videos
yes i do blogging in my skirt sam
yes you can pick on me all you [ __ ]
want to
hey sam you're getting
dunked on by a guy in a skirt
how does that feel because he is putting
his
balls in your mouth and it's easy easy
access because of the skirt
you see that that's why dustin wears
skirts
so you can [ __ ] teabag his haters
easily
he doesn't have time for any button fly
jeans
all right you're getting [ __ ]
humiliated
honestly not just dunked on you're
getting humiliated
by dustin sam doesn't realize
that there's 243 people in your chat
right now
calling him an [ __ ] yeah that's right
that's [ __ ] hey sam
keep playing keep [ __ ] playing
huh you [ __ ] do me a favor
go drive your house off a cliff what do
you do that
huh go do that huh go put more house
juice
in your [ __ ] car if he's in
california house juice is very expensive
yeah yeah why don't you go back to slab
city with the other [ __ ] mutants
you [ __ ] fallout ghoul huh huh
you bc [ __ ] your new vegas npc
he has a new california area he's
running out there
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
another nomad sam fan trust me royce the
list goes around the block
i mean xena is used to a lot ain't she
used you prying fanger
um this says something about micro penis
but i won't even go there saying my mind
works crazy i'll i'll get off that
dude how do all these homeless people
afford to have phones with live
streaming capabilities
it's it's [ __ ] mind-blowing so this
is another nomad fan
yeah it is this is another one of his
little trolls that he's riding around
with
ah these [ __ ] people
oh wait they live in california they get
free subsidies on everything
i don't know if they live in california
i think they live in slab city which is
arizona
so i thought slab city was no step city
nevada nevada
i don't think it's california but i do
have a home
he has a home beat you there my home is
bigger than your home
at least my home is not a [ __ ] van
i can't i can't
[ __ ] confident dustin is my
favorite dustin
my home is a single-wide mobile home
you can call me a trailer park trash all
you want to i don't live in the park you
son of a [ __ ]
jj says it's live streaming i live in
california oh it is 15 acres you
i don't know all that area he's even
known fifteen waiters
[ __ ] it dustin is 15 acres that's bigger
than some parking lots you sleep in sam
this is bigger than the walmart he's
parked at right yeah [ __ ] it seriously
bastard
take that in your freaking pipe and
smoke it
and guess what sam all them cigarettes
you're gonna
smoke uh
i'm gonna remind you
if you get cancer that's on you
[ __ ]
you know smoking is bad for you
but you know what's worse dustin
smoking to kill you dust it'll murder
you
[Laughter]
sam and you're overweight
and you have a bad hip and you as ugly
as a [ __ ]
yes you look just like
a freaking freddy cougar came out of his
ass
that's what your face looks freddy
krueger's already ugly but imagine
something coming out of his ass
that's gonna be more ugly than freddy
krueger that's a [ __ ]
fact that's a [ __ ] fact
like when freddy cougar took a [ __ ]
that's your face that's what your face
looks like
everybody don't like you sam oh no
you only have 160 subscribers oh again
oh yeah i blocked your [ __ ] ass too
anyway [ __ ]
oh i should i should have roasted your
ass a long time ago when you came in my
live stream
and talking all that [ __ ] yeah actually
world did made a mistake yeah i get to
that
but you don't have to come and threaten
me
when you threaten me [ __ ]
no i'll be coming for you
be with a damn big ass truck
before before i slamming it into your
van
i'll take your dogs first and molish
that piece of [ __ ]
a van of yours you wouldn't have no ride
because i'll take a damn jacked up ford
f-150
and crush that piece of [ __ ] right you
got
hell this sounds like a damn
v6
[Music]
thank you all of that sam cause you got
a van
are you trying to be a soccer mom
you are a soccer mom with them big tent
for you
can you play that back i have to of
course i'm going to play that
you're a soccer mom with those big ass
you look just like a freaking freddy
cougar
came out of his ass that's what your
face looks like
when freddy cougar took a [ __ ] that's
your face
that's what your face looks like
everybody don't like you sam
you only have 160 subscribers
oh yeah i blocked your [ __ ] ass too
anyway [ __ ]
i should i should have roasted your ass
a long time ago when you came in my live
stream
and talking all that [ __ ] yeah actually
world did made a mistake yeah i get to
that
but you don't have to come and threaten
me
when you threaten me [ __ ]
no i'll be coming for you i'll be with a
damn
big ass truck before
before i slamming it into your van
i'll take your dog first and molish that
piece of [ __ ]
a van of yours you wouldn't have no
ride because i'll take a damn jacked up
ford f-150 and crush that piece of [ __ ]
ride you got
hell it sounds like a damn
v6 on steroids
[Music]
thank you all that sam because you got a
van
well you trying to be a soccer mom
oh i forgot through you are a soccer mom
with them big tits to yours
[Laughter]
sam we see right through you bro
we see all we see through your [ __ ]
but let me tell you something you
[ __ ]
you ever threatened ashley
brown again
that'd be the last time you ever say a
[ __ ] word
because you will be locked up in a
georgia
prison and they like big booties like
you [ __ ]
the big black boys will stick a big [ __ ]
in your ass
damn i need to stop drinking while we're
watching this holy [ __ ]
you're getting [ __ ] in the ass bro
[ __ ] dustin just told you you
got [ __ ] in the ass by a bbc too
yeah and adonis is right this is what
happens when you [ __ ] with zombie squad
yeah don't mess it as somebody's [ __ ]
why don't you take a video of them
taking advantage of you sam
said hey this is no mess sam
i'm getting [ __ ] ass today
i don't think he needs my help anymore
i'll be honest with you i think this was
inside of him all the time
oh man this man is alabama
adonis
we see right through your [ __ ] every
damn time
how every time i every time i say your
name
my dog oh no oh no
i always throw up you don't like your
name
you're making his dog puke sam
and when my little miniature pomeranian
does when i mention your name
she wants to eat your face but guess
what though
when you threaten one of my zombie
squads
danny i know you're a wrestler do you
have any spots he can't wrestle because
of his asthma for a manager
because i honestly think dustin would be
one of the best managers in the indie
wrestling league i mean
look have you seen have you seen a
better promo car
what [ __ ] fantastic promo he cut on
him
this is old this is like an old ecw
promo because it's naughty
but a [ __ ] this is a great ecw promo
even the promo when he was challenging
the other uh youtubers
yeah the rest of them
is coming after you now
this is what i'm gonna do rest of the
zombie squads
battle up guys we got somebody
threatening one of our own
let's go to battle let's get
no mass sam danny already said he could
be his paul heyman
that's your manager right there [ __ ]
you imagine this guy cutting all the
promos
i'm a dustin guy he's all danny danny i
got
danny i got this give me that microphone
listen here you son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're making my dog puke you don't
want to mess with danny
or else you'll end up in prison getting
[ __ ] by some black boys
what a great line and guess what
we just don't have just zombie squad
what else do we have we also got demon
squads too
who's the demon squad wait there's a
zombie and a demon squad
i think zombie squad's his thing and
remember that guy demons oh yeah yeah
yeah that's team
okay okay okay yeah yeah what about day
waivers oh dude yeah but
day waivers are just zombie squads i
look i'll concede day waivers just
became zombie squad
all right we're the zombies we're part
of the zombie squad
what's the elitist force in the military
green berets where the green birds yeah
we're the ss of the zombie squad we're
the ss of the zombie squad how about
that huh
we're the toughest best dressed too
we're the toughest ones
women's squads is going to be the zombie
squads
and the demon squads coming after you
sam
you don't know what the hell is going to
happen to you because guess what
every video you make you [ __ ]
i'm gonna flag them i'm gonna have your
ass
banned from youtube oh oh hey dustin we
don't do that around these parts
i'm gonna have a talk with him make sure
he doesn't do that yeah i don't like
that piece of [ __ ]
then again the guy did make a threat on
time
he did threaten to kill people he
threatened you hold on a second i'm
having second thoughts here
you're right dustin was minding his own
business
and he made threats to murder people so
you know what
in that case that is violence
that's the threat of violence too he
threatened to drive to york he'd rather
drive to my house and kill me so hold on
a second
you know what dustin [ __ ] him because
he's not doing it out of
malice he's doing it out of uh he's
protecting he's protecting his friends
see because that's an actual tos thing
so you know what no no no you're right i
didn't think about that
you're making threats on people's lives
and sam
good luck doing your stream on d live i
don't even think sam knows what d
live is i don't think [ __ ] sam knows
what a shower is he is a stream yard
come on
he's a stream yard guy [ __ ] you sam
nah it's not just it's not jarva level
because he's not doing it out of mouse
he's doing it because the guy's
threatening to kill people yeah he's
okay he's and also
to be fair he's not hiding it true he's
he's also being very
upfront i'm on team dustin i don't care
what anybody [ __ ] tells me now i will
be a little selfish i don't want sam
off of youtube i want sam to always be
on youtube but that's just because the
entertainment that comes out of this is
just
is next level is [ __ ] next level so
maybe do have the conversation with him
and just be like i'm going to talk to
him i'm like you know what
we have to we have to okay um do we have
time today
no this is going to take really long we
don't have time today i'm going to talk
to i'm going to talk to him off here
i'll tell you that i will
i will talk to him